excuse me i'm sorry all right sure
hello everybody uh hello everybody
hello everyone
listen up
uh first i i i want to thank you all for
coming here today to honor my dear betty
but there's something else i'd like to
say and
i got to get it off my chest i mean i i
was gonna tell betty but
now that looks like that isn't gonna
happen
i can't live with this anymore i i can't
live with the guild
i had an affair with
helen fahey
listen a fair strong word very strong it
happened twice
okay three times tops but you know then
the fact that i can't even remember how
many should tell you all you need to
know about what it meant to me
i mean what kind of smack this makes an
announcement like that his wife's
funeral reception anyway
[Music]
mom what do you think i thought you were
wearing the red dress with the with the
thing
i tried didn't work no no no no go go
back and try the red dress again
he's at the door mom oh oh in that case
you look great
homewrecker
holy [ __ ] let's go let's go bye
you